So it should be clear how
important genetic analysis is for
reconstructing evolutionary trees.
Yet it has not always been so clear.
When Zuckerkandl and Pauling wrote, half a
century ago, that hemoglobin offered a good
basis for comparing humans to gorillas,
prominent biologist Gaylord Simpson
shot them down in impressive fashion,
saying that their proposal was nonsense.
Now today, Simpson lies on
the wrong side of history, but
at the time, perhaps Zuckerkandl and
Pauling were the radicals.
Since that time, genetic analysis has
been applied to answer a huge number
of biological questions related to
evolutionary tree reconstruction.
For example, until the 1980s,
it was unclear whether the giant panda
should be classified as a bear or
as a RACCOON (not marsupial).
The giant panda looks like
a bear in some ways, but
it's also similar to
raccoons in other ways.
The panda doesn't hibernate in the winter,
and its male genitalia are tiny and
backward-pointing.
I'm going to let you insert
your own joke on that one.
In 1938, Edwin Colbert wrote,
"so the quest has stood for
many years with the bear proponents, and
the raccoon adherents, and the middle of
the road group advancing their several
arguments with the clearest of logic.
While in the meantime,
the giant panda lives serenely in the
mountains of Sichuan with never a thought
about the zoological controversies
he is causing by just being himself."
Now, whereas using anatomical or
behavioral characters led to
endless debate in this subject,
Steve O'Brien used genetic data in 1985 to
demonstrate that the giant panda should,
in fact, be considered a bear -
a conclusion that has lasted to this day.
We can also turn genetic analysis
inward onto ourselves, and
construct an evolutionary tree for
human populations.
When we look at this tree, we see
a very clear division into Africans,
shown in red, and non-Africans,
shown in other colors, where each color
represents a different continent.
But we also see that the most recent
common ancestor of all non-Africans is
at a much more recent point than the most
recent common ancestor of all Africans,
which is at the root of the tree.
In 1987 Rebecca Cann, Mark Stoneking and
Allan Wilson deduced from this information
that because the origin of modern humans
predates the origin of all non Africans,
all non-Africans must have
originated somewhere in Africa.
This became known as
the out-of-Africa hypothesis.
And although it is still
the subject of some debate,
it has become widely accepted today.
As more genotyping data has been obtained,
researchers have been able
to infer human migrations around
the world from evolutionary trees.
Yet this is not to say that genetic
data immediately is able to answer
all of our questions.
One problem arises when different genetic
data sets yield differing phylogenies.
For example,
using the dopamine D4 receptor gene
suggested that chimpanzees were closer
to gorillas than they were to humans.
On the other hand, if we used
the beta-globin gene, that suggested that
chimpanzees were closer to humans
than they were to gorillas.
Not until 1996 did enough
genetic data become available
to conclude that the phylogeny on
the right is most likely the correct one.
Even at the beginning of this century,
many biologists believed
that humans are more closely related to
dogs than humans are related to mice.
This seems reasonable,
since we seem to be more similar
to dogs than mice at first glance.
But recent research has shown otherwise,
as indicated by this phylogeny.
Finally, evolutionary trees constructed
from genetic analysis have even been
used as evidence in criminal trials.
A landmark instance of this occurred in
1998, when a doctor in Louisiana went on
trial for the attempted murder
of his estranged mistress.
She claimed that he had injected
her with an HIV-tainted syringe.
After the police chief collected
HIV samples from around the area,
researchers constructed an evolutionary
tree for these samples.
And what they found was that
the HIV samples from the victim,
shown here in blue,
were similar to samples taken from one
of the doctor's patients, shown in red.
This evidence supports conviction,
which was the eventual verdict.
But this evolutionary tree taken
by itself is far from conclusive,
which is what brings us to
the challenge problem for this chapter.
The evolutionary tree that we
constructed on the previous slide
was constructed based on an alignment
of just one HIV protein.
What happens when you construct
alignments for other HIV proteins?
Do they all support conviction?
Or do some of these other
proteins paint a murkier picture?
So I will let you go and
work on implementing the algorithms for
evolutionary tree construction that
we have encountered in this chapter.
I want to say thank you for
joining me on this journey.
I can only hope that this chapter
has been as enjoyable for
you as it has been for me.